تشكيل مجلس النواب الامريكي لجنه قضائيه
فرعيه للتحقيق بما يسمى بتسليح الحكومه
الفدراليه خطوه جديده نحو احتدام الصراع
بين الجمهوريين واداره بيضه فمهام اللجنه
الفرعيه ستشمل وفقه مراقبين مراجعه
التحقيقات مع الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
والخوض في القضايا القانونيه التي تدور
حوله وسيكون لديها سلطه الاشراف على
التحقيقات الجنائيه الجاريه كما يمكنها
الوصول الى نفس المعلومات التي تطلع عليها
لجنه الاستخبارات
وضعها
الدستوري في الاشراف على الاداره هذا من
واجباتنا لقد تم اهمالها خلال العامين
الماضيين سنجري اشراف قويا للتاكد من ان
اموالنا في عيد ضرائب انفقت بشكل صحيح
وللتخلص من الهدر والاحتيال وسوء المعامله
التي رايناها في الحكومه من المجموعات
الحكوميه
كما ستحقق اللجنه الفرعيه التي سيراسها
جيم جوردن المقرب من ترامب في الاتصالات
بين شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى واداره ايضا
للضغط على المحافظين على الانترنت
وتشكيل هذه اللجنه الفرعيه هي احدى هذه
الوعوده وواحده من اوائل المواجهات مع
الديمقراطيين خلال العامين المقبلين
يعتبرون ان تشكيلها لجنه الفرعيه احد
التنازلات التي قدمها رئيس المجلس كيف
المقارتي اليمنيين جمهورينا للفوز بمطرقه
المجلس معتبرين ان ذلك ليس من مصلحه
مع قياده من جانب الاغلبيه من مصلحتنا
التاكد من اننا نمثل دور الكونجرس والشعب
الامريكيين ليس لديهم فرصه خلف الابواب
مغلقه لاضافه نظريات المؤامرات هذه
وفيما يتهم الجمهوريون الديمقراطيين بما
يسمى بتسليح الحكومه الفيدراليه يرى
الديمقراطيون ان هذه اللجنه الفرعيه
الجديده هي السلاح نفسه حسين الطاوض
العربيه واشنطن